welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is fad dining an associate professor of
political science at Yale University
professor Dunning studies comparative
politics political economy and
methodology his book crude democracy
natural resource wealth and political
regimes contrasts the Democratic and
authoritarian effects of natural
resource wealth his current work on
ethnic and other cleavages draws on
field and natural experiments and
qualitative fieldwork in Latin America
India and Africa
professor Dunning has written on a range
of methodological topics including
econometrics ins for selection effects
and the use of natural experiments in
the social sciences today we'll talk
with him about a study he recently
completed on voting in Mali
welcome professor Dunning thank you so
much your paper that you've recently
written is the titleist quite a mouthful
cross-cutting cleavages and ethnic
voting and experimental study of
kusanagi
and Mali what is cusan I thought
very good question well Mali is in the
Western Sahara no sub-saharan Africa
it's to the north of the Ivory Coast and
to the East to Senegal it's a beautiful
country with with all kinds of
interesting features and it was in
particular the site of the Mali Empire
which was consolidated under the reign
of Sundiata Keita in the 13th century
and was one of the stronger of the
pre-colonial African empires had
extended west to Senegal to the Guinea
to to Guinea in the Gambia and a little
bit south into northern Ivory Coast as
well
and one of the features of sogeti Kita's
rule was the institutionalization if you
will of the social practice of Kucinich
what is kuzin osh Cruzan --oj is a kind
of social institution that links Malians
with particular last names or
afternoons into into a set a series of
social relations and often there's
joking that occurs between cousins so if
like someone named Keita in the streets
of Bamako which is Mali's capital meets
some stranger perhaps in the street
named Coulibaly because the Keita and
the Coulibaly are so-called joking
cousins they may exchange a series of
pleasantries and this link between
joking cousins or fictive cousins which
the French call kucinich is is what's
the object of what what we were studying
in Mali
I see so what is the premise in your
paper what are you arguing in it well
there's a puzzle in Mali which is that
Molly is very ethnically heterogeneous
there are 11 or 12 major linguistically
defined ethnic groups in Mali but
ethnicity doesn't seem to play a very
important political role so ethnicity
isn't a salient in terms of party
platforms and individual ethnicity is
not a strong predictor of how people
vote and this is a puzzle in sub-saharan
Africa where many many other countries
in fact have more a more salient role
for ethnicity so this is the puzzle
that's that's interesting in Mali and a
hypothesis that's been that but that's
been - proposed to explain the lack of
salience of ethnicity is is precisely
cruising osh and cruising arts relations
are a specific instance of a more
general phenomenon which has has often
been of interest to political scientists
which is cross-cutting it's an example
of a cross-cutting cleavage which is the
other part of the mouthful in the title
that you mentioned and what is a
cross-cutting cleavages cutting cleavage
is a dimension of interest or identity
along which members people who are
members of the same group on a different
dimension may be members of different
groups so think about social class and
ethnicity as one potentially
cross-cutting cleavage and in in another
setting in Mali kusanagi is a is a
cleavage that cross cut social class
because people who are members of the
same ethnic group may or may not be be
joking cousins
and people who are members of two
different ethnic groups may in fact be
may in fact be joking cousins and so on
this hypothesis Cuza nosh may be a
dimension of a kind of social
relationship that Crosscut's
ethnicity and helps to explain the
limited salience of ethnicity in in
social and maybe even political life in
Hualien
this is a hypothesis that's been
advanced and casually informally by
diplomats in fact if you go to the u.s.
Department of State website it in
attributes the lack of ethnic conflict
in Mali at least in part to the presence
of the social institution Kreuznach and
it was the object of study for serious
anthropologists at that in the first
half of the 20th century names people
like Radcliffe Brown studied joking
kinship Marcel Mauss other luminaries of
mythology studied joking kinships around
the world in cruising Ozzie and Molly in
particular what we wanted to do in this
study was to assess whether there's some
relations political relationship between
in particular or relationship between
cruising dodging and vote choice okay
prior to this paper you wrote a book
called crude democracy the was the
research that you did for that book did
that give way to the idea of the
research you're doing in Mali well how
did you end up in Mali
well crude democracy might seem like a
very dissimilar kind of topic because
that book is about how natural resource
wealth affects political regimes and
there's an idea in the political science
literature and among in the popular
press that that natural resources
promote a Thorat Arianism there are lots
of examples of a resource-rich
authoritarian states like in the Middle
East in the Gulf states and so on and
what I tried to do in that book was
argue that actually natural resources
could have conditional effects in some
conditions they might well promote
authoritarianism but in other kinds of
conditions they could have more
democratizing effects and so it might
seem very very dissimilar on the other
hand what what the book was really about
is relationships between particular
groups of citizens in that book between
relationships between the rich and the
poor and how a kind of economic
dimension
cross-cut in a way or blunted the the
class conflict that might otherwise
ensue in very unequal societies and so
the argument was that oil resources oil
rents and the jargon provide a source of
revenue that that funds public spending
without forcing the state to to impose
redistributive taxes so it was about oil
but it was really about social relations
and particularly relations between
classes so I think this this idea about
how different cleavage dimensions or
dimensions of interest or identity
relate to one another and shaped
political outcomes this basically what
what I what I've been studying for a
long time and this is in a in a sort of
different manifestation I taught a class
here at Yale and on ethnic politics in
comparative perspective and had a very
talented undergraduate in my class who
was interested in the phenomenon of
Christina Hutchins wrote a an excellent
term paper about it so I suggested that
we we study cruising --oj systematically
and try to assess whether there really
is an influence of kusanagi on on
political behavior and then in turn on
sort of broader political outcomes so
Lauren Harrison who is Yale College
class of 2009 was my co-author on the
paper that I'm talking about today okay
and for the paper you developed an
experimental research design unlike any
others how is it different well what we
did in in bamako which is Molly's
capital is was to canvass all of the
neighborhoods in Bamako and and take a
sample of participants for a study and
then we showed participants videotaped
political speeches they were intended to
be as much like a routine political
speech that that a Malian would
encounter in any campaign any kind of
legislative campaign and because last
name or surname in Mali indicates both
ethnicity and linkages and the kucinich
networks by manipulating or changing
this the the last name of the politician
in our speech we could manipulate we
hoped perceptions both of the
politicians ethnicity and of of his
kusanagi linkages to to the subject who
was watching the speech
and because we were concerned of course
that physical features and so on might
indicate ethnicity we used to tried this
with a few different actors of many
different ethnicities and in fact found
that that surname just by changing the
surname we could quite dramatically
shift people's perceptions of the of the
ethnicity of the politician as well as
the placement of the politician in
cruising osh networks so we basically
had a range of what social scientists
called treatment conditions which were
defined by whether the politician was a
cousin or not a cousin of the subject in
the experiment of the participant in the
experiment and also whether the
politician was a co ethnic or non
Catholic
and then we had some control conditions
as as social scientists and other
scientists like to call them where no
ethnicity about us no information about
ethnicity or Kreuznach links were was
provided to the to the subject and so
that allowed us to assess how the
relationship between the subject and the
politician effected evaluations of the
speech so in a post experiment survey or
post treatment survey we asked subjects
whether they would vote to what extent
they would they felt they were likely to
vote for the politician and then a
series of questions that taps their
impressions of the politicians
likability competence intelligence and
so on and so what we're interested in is
whether changing the perceived ethnic
relationship and Cruz and ours
relationship between the subject and
politician shifted around their
evaluations of the candidate so what
were your conclusions based on the
research in Mali well we found that Cruz
Nagy did shape the way that people saw
politicians so they were more favorable
towards their joking cousins and one of
the reasons for this may be that they
tended to have more friends who were
cousins these are other kinds of data
that we we gathered after the experiment
from subjects but in contrast to the
idea that ethnicity is not sailing they
also preferred their Co ethnics and what
we found though is that the penalty that
politicians paid for being non couette
Nix of voters or subjects in the
experiment was made up for by the
positive boost
of being a cousin so the the politicians
who were rated the worst were non
couette Knick non cousins and the
politicians who were rated the most
favorably were cousins conics
politicians were both cousins and co
ethnics of the subject but but the
effect of going from being a co co
ethnic to a non-core thermic was about
the same as going from being a cousin to
ananka as and non cousin so that non
co-ed Nick cousins were evaluations of
non cathodic cousins were
indistinguishable statistically from
from evaluations of of cousins who were
non kaletnik's so that's that was the
basic finding that that kind of
cross-cutting
logic that that has been alleged seemed
seemed to hold up and in our experiment
and then the big question was well does
this explain that the puzzle that we
says help explain the puzzle we set out
just to try to explain and can your
research design be useful in other
settings I think it can of course there
are some specific aspects of the malian
study that the word idiosyncratic so one
of the big challenges in doing this kind
of this work in Mali was that we had to
create a big matrix that for every
subject last name that is every
ethnicity we a subject ethnicity and
last name that we expected to encounter
in in in the field while doing our
research and going door to door from
house to house in Bamako we had to
create a big matrix which listed the
names of politicians associated with
each of those treatment conditions that
I mentioned and so that kind of design
challenge was idiosyncratic to Mali but
the idea of using political speeches and
manipulating the relationship between
subjects and the politician along not
just one but but sort of multiple
dimensions I think is exportable and so
I've been doing a series of studies
actually using a very similar design in
in India most recently in India South
Africa and Brazil as well so those in
addition the Mali project are projects
that I've been working on well on
recently on sabbatical from research
sabbatical from teaching and and they're
the design is very similar so I think it
does provide kind of
useful tool for thinking about how
different dimensions of interest or
identity might shape political
preferences very good well thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your research thank you
so much for having me for more
information about Professor Dunning and
his work please visit our website at
yale.edu McMillan Report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
McMillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
McMillan Center for International and
area studies at yam
you